Transcription: fabienne boissier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
Vous avez déjà vu un surdoué ?
Moi, je commence à en voir partout.
A l’école maintenant,
tous les élèves sont surdoués.
On en voit de plus en plus à la télé,
et je ne vous parle pas
des réseaux sociaux.
Alors voilà, pour
les reconnaître, c’est facile.
Ils ont une grosse tête,
donc forcément, pour compenser,
ils ont un petit corps.
Donc ils sont mauvais en sport,
mais, par contre, ce sont les premiers
de la classe en maths.
Ils ont des lunettes en cul de bouteille.
Et puis, ils sont prétentieux,
arrogants, condescendants,
plutôt geeks, un peu asociaux,
voire à la limite autistes.
Ou alors, un surdoué, ça peut
ressembler à Morgane Alvaro,
le personnage que joue Audrey Fleurot
dans « HPI, Haut Potentiel Intellectuel ».
Déjà, là, on a une femme.
C’est une adulte, en plus.
Au début de l’histoire,
elle est agent d’entretien.
Donc, on avance un peu, là,
dans la perception.
Je vais maintenant
vous proposer un petit jeu.
C’est le jeu des célébrités.
En fait, parmi ces célébrités,
je vais vous demander :
lesquelles, pensez vous, sont surdouées ?
Et je vais vous demander de lever la main.
Donc, la première, c’est Sharon Stone.
Qui pense qu’elle est surdouée ?
Allez-y, n’ayez pas peur...
Oui, même pas la moitié ?
La comédienne qui joue
dans « Big Bang Theory »,
qui, pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas,
est justement une série sur les surdoués.
Attention, il y a peut-être un piège !
Donc, qui pense qu’elle est surdouée ?
Ah, il y en a un peu moins !
Quentin Tarantino : lui, vu la tête
qu’il a, il est un peu spécial.
Il doit sûrement être surdoué. Alors ?
Ah oui, là, il en y en a
beaucoup plus, c’est marrant.
Cindy Crawford,
qui pense qu’elle est surdouée ?
Oui, pas beaucoup !
Michael Jordan ?
Ah, beaucoup plus !
Le comédien qui joue Mister Bean ?
Ah oui, ça c’est pas mal !
Il y en a beaucoup là.
Et la dernière, c’est la comédienne
qui joue Phoebe dans « Friends ».
Oui, c’est entre deux.
Donc, en fait, si vous avez levé la main
à chaque fois, vous avez raison,
parce que toutes ces célébrités ont
un quotient intellectuel au-dessus de 130.
Alors, il serait intéressant
de comprendre sur quels critères
vous avez fabriqué votre choix
par rapport à ces célébrités.
Mais, ce n’est pas là mon propos.
En fait, ce que je voudrais
simplement vous démontrer,
c’est qu’on se fait souvent une idée
élitiste du haut potentiel intellectuel,
alors que c’est un sujet
qui est complètement inclusif.
Il touche toutes les catégories sociales,
autant d’hommes que de femmes,
quel que soit leur âge,
quelles que soient
leurs origines ethniques,
leurs préférences sexuelles,
leurs convictions religieuses,
leurs opinions politiques
ou philosophiques.
Le thème de cette journée
est l’exploration,
et j’ai donc pensé vous faire
découvrir cette diversité cognitive.
Le faire ici, dans une école
qui va former de futurs managers,
ça prend tout son sens.
C’est une diversité qui n’est pas visible,
dont le Haut Potentiel Intellectuel
fait partie, mais pas seulement.
Les autres composantes de cette diversité
sont parfois appelées « troubles »,
ou considérées comme des troubles :
les troubles des apprentissages
avec le monde des DYS -
dyslexie, dyspraxie, dyscalculie -
les troubles de déficit de l’attention
avec ou sans hyperactivité,
ou les troubles du spectre autistique.
Tous ces câblages neuronaux font partie
de la variation naturelle
des cognitions dans la population.
Le HPI (Haut Potentiel intellectuel),
c’est moins de 2,5 % de la population.
Mais, si on y ajoute les autres câblages
dont on vient de parler,
on peut facilement atteindre
plus de 20 % de la population.
Ça veut dire que, dans cette salle,
il y a une trentaine de personnes
qui est concernée par le sujet,
et dont certaines ne savent
même pas qu’elles le sont.
Personnellement, j'ai 54 ans.
À 40 ans, j’ai appris
que j’étais dyslexique.
Honnêtement,
je n’en ai pas fait grand chose.
C’était juste super cool parce que là,
j’avais au moins une super excuse
pour les fautes d’orthographe.
J’ai un fils de 15 ans,
et c’est grâce à lui
que j’ai découvert, à 48 ans,
que j’étais Haut Potentiel Intellectuel.
Pour ma part, j’ai donc un double câblage,
une double exceptionnalité.
Je suis à la fois DYS et HPI.
Dans les pays anglo-saxons,
on appelle ça : « Twice-Exceptional ».
Je me suis alors demandé
ce que je pouvais faire de tout ça.
Et c’est comme ça qu’il y a cinq ans,
j’ai cocréé avec ma collègue Céline Tovar,
un réseau, dans mon entreprise,
pour adresser ce sujet.
Alors, qu’est ce que cette population
peut apporter dans le monde du travail ?
Ça, ce sont les différents câblages...
j’ai oublié la slide.
En fait, il faut voir le sujet comme
un ensemble de forces et de faiblesses.
Dans les forces, les personnes
à Haut Potentiel Intellectuel
voient les sujets en termes de solutions,
adorent la complexité,
sont agiles en interfaces,
créent des liens, sont créatifs,
sont innovants,
sont capables de disruption.
Par contre, elles n’ont pas forcément
toujours une grande estime d’elles-mêmes.
Il peut y avoir beaucoup de frustrations
liées aux incompréhensions
et au décalage avec les autres.
Elles s’ennuient à exécuter
des tâches qui sont routinières.
Elles sont exigeantes avec elles-mêmes,
mais aussi avec les autres.
Les dyslexiques, eux,
ne voient pas les mots
comme des phonèmes
qu’ils traduisent en graphèmes,
mais comme des images,
des concepts et des idées.
La grande force d’un cerveau
qui fonctionne par images,
c’est qu’il imagine.
Ils imaginent des solutions,
des innovations, des modèles,
Ils imaginent hors de la boîte.
Les dyslexiques excellent
dans la résolution de problèmes
parce qu’en fait, ils ont développé
plein de stratégies de contournement
et utilisent les voies détournées de leur
cerveau pour interpréter différemment,
pour tester des possibles
sous plusieurs angles.
Ils ont aussi une grande
capacité d’abstraction
et de perception en trois,
quatre, voire cinq dimensions.
Côté faiblesses, elles sont évidemment
liées aux apprentissages
qui passent encore beaucoup par l’écrit.
Et puis, évidemment, il y a l’orthographe.
Donc, à l’école, c’est compliqué.
Pour les dyslexiques, l’école,
c’est souvent Omaha Beach.
Il y en a beaucoup
qui meurent sur la plage.
Mais de leurs difficultés d’apprentissage,
des dyslexiques ont appris
la ténacité, la motivation,
et le goût de l’effort.
Ils deviennent de grands architectes
grâce à leur vision en 3D,
comme Norman Foster, qui est
le concepteur du viaduc de Millau.
Mais, on peut citer aussi,
dans les dyslexiques,
Edison, Faraday, Tesla, Pasteur,
Eisenhower, Churchill, Branson,
Steve Jobs, Spielberg,
Picasso, Walt Disney ou Agatha Christie.
Si on parle maintenant des personnes
à Haut Potentiel avec autisme,
elles ont un sens précis du détail,
c’est-à-dire qu’elles arrivent
à détecter des erreurs
dans des lignes et des lignes
de codes informatiques.
Elles trouvent des patterns,
c’est-à-dire des séquences qui se répètent
en faisant de l’analyse de données.
J’ai un exemple, dans l’entreprise
dans laquelle je suis,
d’un collaborateur qui justement
trouvait des patterns,
alors que des algorithmes faits pour ça
ne les détectaient pas.
Elles ont une expertise encyclopédique
et fiable dans leur domaine d’intérêt.
Par contre, elles peuvent avoir
des difficultés d’interaction,
de compréhension des implicites,
un stress par rapport
à certaines situations,
ou par rapport à certains environnements
qui ne seraient pas adaptés pour elles.
Les services de renseignement israéliens
utilisent, par exemple, des personnes
dans le spectre autistique
pour décrypter des images satellites.
Une grande entreprise comme SAP
s’est donnée l’objectif
d’avoir 1 % de ses collaborateurs
dans le spectre autistique,
pas seulement pour les hyper compétences
dont on vient de parler,
mais aussi parce que ça crée un climat
d’écoute mutuelle dans les équipes,
et ce climat d’écoute mutuelle
fonctionne aussi
pour les personnes qui ne sont pas
concernées par l’autisme.
Vous seriez peut-être surpris d’apprendre
que certaines personnes se situent
dans le spectre autistique
ou ont été suspectées rétrospectivement
d’être dans le spectre autistique,
par exemple, Abraham Lincoln,
Thomas Jefferson,
Isaac Newton, Bill Gates, Woody Allen,
Kubrick, Andy Warhol, Albert Einstein,
Vincent Van Gogh,
ou le sismologue Charles Richter.
Dans le monde du travail, les enjeux
vont s’articuler autour de deux volets :
le volet humain
et le volet de performance,
donc, responsabilité sociale
et retour sur investissement.
Cette diversité s’inscrit également
dans un contexte de guerre des talents
pour attirer et conserver
les meilleurs talents.
Côté humain, cette population
sera plus sujette
au burnout, au harcèlement,
et comme toute diversité,
il y a de vrais enjeux d’inclusion,
sans stigmatiser.
Le réseau que nous avons créé
permet à notre population
de se sentir légitime
dans leurs différences
et d’exprimer ainsi leurs talents.
Il permet aussi de travailler l’écart,
les incompréhensions,
de travailler la convergence,
donc l’inclusion.
Enfin, il permet de rompre l’isolement lié
à la difficulté de trouver des pairs.
Côté business, aujourd’hui,
tout évolue très vite.
Tout est hyper connecté, hypersensible.
Et le business fonctionne par disruption.
On peut voir la richesse
de cette diversité, encore une fois,
au travers des hyper
compétences dont on a parlé,
mais aussi, surtout, au travers
de l’intelligence collective.
Les études ont montré
que la diversité, en général,
est un levier de performance par
la création de l’intelligence collective.
Et c’est encore plus vrai
pour cette diversité cognitive.
Afin de le démontrer,
dans notre entreprise,
nous avons lancé une expérimentation
qui a été portée par le business.
Et, en travaillant avec deux coachs
sur la convergence
et sur les irritants en interface,
cette diversité à créé
de la valeur au-delà des espérances.
Notre réseau a donc ouvert la voie.
Et depuis, d’autres réseaux se sont créés
dans la banque, dans l’assurance,
d’autres entreprises aéronautiques,
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques,
le ferroviaire, l’industrie électrique,
l’automobile, les télécommunications,
et la fonction publique.
Et aujourd’hui, nous nous sommes réunis
au travers d’un collectif des réseaux
sur la diversité cognitive au travail,
afin d’aider et accompagner
la création de nouveaux réseaux.
Donc, si vous avez l’envie, l’intention,
de créer un réseau dans votre entreprise,
prenez contact avec nous
et venez nous rejoindre.
Pour conclure cette présentation,
je dirais que la diversité cognitive
est un vecteur d’intelligence
collective dans le travailler-ensemble,
enrichi par nos différences.
Le plus gros challenge,
c’est de s’appuyer sur ce qui nous réunit,
sans gommer ce qui fait de nous
des êtres singuliers.
Nous ne sommes encore
qu’au début de cette histoire.
Il y a tout à créer,
et finalement,
c’est ça qui est passionnant,
peut-être parce que nous avons conservé
dans notre ADN l’esprit des pionniers.
Je vais vous laisser avec la citation
d’un grand explorateur,
pilote, écrivain, poète et aventurier,
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry :
« Ta différence,
loin de me léser, m’enrichit. »
Merci à tous pour votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)